[Music]
absolutely
what a lad and this is it the moment you
have all been waiting for
there hasn't been this much talk around
a decision since lebron left the cavs
and today a legendary lad who has been
on the walled podcast before and told a
story already but today he will be
announcing his future
there's been talk around a code switch
to the roosters there's been talk around
staying in japan where he's been
absolutely killing it
or even a return to the new zealand
rugby union
he's a man that everybody wants on their
books for good reason
it is the absolute great lad himself tj
perenata welcome brother kilda brother
thanks for the intro brains a lot of
nice things she said here
so thanks for that bro it's good to be
here hey mate thanks for coming on
really appreciate you coming on this is
obviously a lot of people have been
talking about this over the last few
weeks
it's a big decision how's it how's it
been how's the whole
how's the whole last month been for you
um yeah it's been pretty full on bro
it's um
it's been hard not to um to think about
it and to hit because i
obviously want to focus on playing well
here um and
getting us deeper in the competition
which
sadly ended for us on the weekend but i
had to just allocate time
to be able to focus on it because it was
always in the back of my mind
when i was trying to just block it all
out so putting that time
aside every day or every couple days to
be able to have the conversations i
needed to have was was really good
yeah it obviously didn't affect your
form though because i know exaggerate a
lot but i'm not exaggerating when i say
you have been absolutely killing it over
there
you've made a huge difference to that
red hurricane's team who were
losing games by hundreds last year and
now they're one of the top
top teams in the competition it's
probably fair to say so
mate your form has been on fire so it
obviously hasn't affected that
thanks bro it's um like we've got a
really good group of guys i'm here with
your brother obviously uh we've got
maori here um always here as well so
being able to have
um all of those minds together um and
really drive our team throughout the
weeks
being uh it's been really cool and i've
enjoyed the footy we spoke a little bit
earlier
i'm playing a little bit different role
over here than i
have been of late in new zealand um and
i've enjoyed it it's
pretty less defending than i'm used to
but and i
i usually prefer to defend more but i'm
getting more touches offensively so it's
been
it's been good oh he loves to defend is
that a hint where he's going
so before we get to the decision who
will the other uh offers
obviously the red hurricanes would have
wanted you back the og keynes would have
wanted you back
um oh they obviously missed you this
season there's been a lot of talk around
the roosters it sounds like they were
really keen was there anyone else who
was on the cards um now
those three were uh the main three there
was a little bit of noise um here in
japan with another club too
uh but we can't really engage with with
other clubs it's
a rule um here i think um based on like
a contract you have to
i think get approval to be able to
negotiate with another club so
there was some noise from from another
club here but nothing
nothing formal but
those three clubs um the hurricanes in
new zealand
and and the roosters were the main ones
that we were sort of talking to
true that's people on it
right well let let's get to it where are
you going um
my wife and i have decided to come home
um so
we're really really excited and really
thankful for
the hurricanes and new zealand rugby for
giving us that opportunity so
uh
as much as i was excited to see you play
for the roosters man the keynes
the kane's going hearing you going back
to the canes is that's
awesome news as a fully full-on keynes
fan
thanks bro it's uh it was it was a
really hard decision bro and it
it come hanzo pretty much last night on
on our decision or yesterday
on our decision um but like my wife and
i had to
to weigh up sort of pros and cons of of
all three decisions really and
coming home um for for us at the family
um pharaoh girl
was was the right decision for us
so how close did you get to the roosters
um
like i reckon we were at a stage
at one point where we might have even
been leaning more towards
i'm going to league and coming back to
japan as a like a dual jewel sort of a
deal
then we were coming home
so yeah like last night was 50 50
um maybe maybe a little bit more in
favor of coming back to new zealand
um but two or three weeks ago
if we had to make that decision on that
day like we
it could have been a different decision
but we uh yeah we were probably
more in favor um we're coming back to
japan and
playing in the narrow wow
so would that have been would that have
been this season's you know
yeah so i would have finished here um
gone and did my isolation in
in sydney and enjoying the team um for
the back end of the year
and we thought we fell into a couple
like um complications with insurance now
i don't know how they got out by the way
but
someone said that
um but that wasn't that wasn't the
deciding factor we
i spoke with um people in the roosters
environment yesterday
and if we decided to do it like we would
have
found a way to make the insurance side
of it work too
uh yeah and so that didn't end up being
um a factor really true
far out that's crazy so the ma the main
reason was for the family because i know
your wife and
baby aren't over in japan with you at
the moment so to get back home and to be
with them that must
have been the main reason i guess yeah
there were two
two really big reasons there were there
was definitely one of them like i
haven't been with
um greer and amaya um since the 30th of
january so that's been
a long time and part of our decision
if we were going to come here we always
knew that there was a potential that
it might happen again risking our
daughter's health
um is just not something we we wanted to
do so
although we don't know what the word's
going to be like in six months
time and it potentially could be fine
and we could have come over as a family
um but there's also that potential that
it might not be
like that and committing to um
a team here in japan and then
having them go home again or not even
come over
would have been too hard like it's
probably been the hardest three or four
months of my life not having
not having them yeah yeah and then the
and then i felt unsettled or not
answered the wrong words
i felt if i don't go back to new zealand
as well there's always part of me
thinking like
i haven't done everything i wanted to do
um there's still some
unfinished business there for me in new
zealand um
and so those were the two the two major
drivers so your wife and baby were over
there at the start but they
moved home because of covert was that
was that the reason they moved home
yeah yeah it was so we um
we can't come up here as a family in
december and cover got pretty bad here
in
uh in osaka and it was it was in the
league at the time there were some teams
that had had covered and
the season was still going ahead and i
couldn't see
um any like any indications that things
were going to change or we're going to
have time off to see if things settle
down at all so
the risk of me going in and playing
footy and training being on the subway
every day
um i i felt like i was at high risk of
getting getting coronavirus and
bringing that home to my wife into baby
um was just too much of a risk for us to
to take like we didn't want to um we
didn't want amaya to get sick and then
she ended up in a hospital over here um
without our families in that here
without
it was the language barrier too which
would have been really difficult so it
just ended up being
a decision for her safety and her health
over a decision for what grinner and
what green and i wanted and what
pain we didn't want to have to feel by
leaving each other you know
fair enough mate fair enough so when
when do you join up with the hurricanes
is that for next season or
is that as soon as possible uh well
so i've signed a two and a half year
deal with new zealand
through the world cup um hopefully wow
awesome
um so leave here and i'm contracted to
new zealand rugby
um so there's injury cover or something
i'm not in the hurricane school for this
year so
um i'll train with them like i'll i'll
tell you
parking
but i don't know how the the details
work like whether i can join squad or
whatever i think if an injury happens
which i don't shouldn't drop on anyone
um but uh
the nature of our game
look at luke campbell you're in trouble
so how many half picks have they got at
the moment they've got three is it
well we've got four so we've got jamie
jamie booth um is he back is he fit now
no sorry he's not fit but he's in the
squad uh we've got luke
and then um for the whole year
um booth was obviously i'm pretty early
on so he's been there for you
so you need an injury to one of those
other guys who are fit at the moment
i'm not sure i think like i don't know
if you have the swap light for life like
a prop goes down
i don't know i can come in or not yeah
i'm unsure
but i will i'll make myself a babe
available and i'll be
i'll be ready to go if the opportunity
does arrive
well that would be his thing straight
back in there
i i'd love to and then but if not i'd
love to be
playing club rugby for north as well so
either way
being back home training with the boys
and then being able to
either play a net competition or play
for north would be cool wow that would
be awesome so
does that make you available for the all
blacks as well
um i'm not sure for that june or july
series
uh yeah at this stage i i think the
rules are you have to play
uh in the new zealand competition like
professional competition to be eligible
unless you've
written it in your contract where i i
didn't have a contract to come back to
so i didn't write that
into anything so i have to play in a
competition
before being eligible for for the all
black so
if i do come in his injury cover um i
guess it might but if not then i don't
think so true man
that is crazy so there'll be a lot of
pressure on one of these nice to get
injured
across the whole country
no we don't want that we don't want that
that wasn't going good
yeah that's true so talk to me a little
bit more about the league so
had you spoken to trent robinson and
staff did it get that close
yeah i had a lot of conversations um
with trent and
um some of their training staff trying
to
where i got to the point where i was
getting
training drills and like conditioning
plans to prepare myself to
say yeah and i'm implementing that into
like my extras and stuff like that um
not not stuff that would distract me or
take me away from playing rugby
but stuff that would be like i could
easily do
at the back end of a training session
that would have really helped me
condition
um and it's going to leak so like a
yeah like i said it earlier it was it
was really really close and it was a
really
really tough decision um i spoke with
trent yesterday
um about it as well hughes um he was in
full support of either decision i made
he understood
the reasons for coming if i came in the
reasons
if i didn't so it's been um it's been
really
really good to work with him on that
level too
is it something you'd potentially look
at down the future maybe
after your contract expires or do you
feel like this was your opportunity
um i'd never say never but like i felt
this was a really good opportunity for
it
like i felt i feel like i'm playing
really good pretty
the game at the moment in league um
suits what i played
for hooker yeah i felt like it gave me
enough time to
do it and do it pretty well especially
coming in
this season halfway through um
would be like a real learning learning
phase
but being able to play as well um would
have been
a good introduction to it and then if i
go well
i don't know the potential of staying on
longer term
um doing japan and then coming back to
the nro again
um there was a lot of discussions about
it and i was like it was really exciting
to be here
so it was hooker and you were looking to
play
straight away was that was that the
feedback that you'd had 80 minutes sorta
hooker
um i'd like to yeah saw me as a hooker i
saw myself as a hooker who
could probably cover in the half if i
needed to like if something happened
um and there was going to be a bit more
of an introduction phase
at the start i don't know
exactly how it would have worked but
they would have
got me with the conditioning team
probably tested me early on
um in the first couple days out of
isolation just to see where i was at and
then what they thought i needed to do
in order to be able to play and then
play yeah
what sort of conditioning stuff were
they giving you was it like tackle stuff
because
i mean that's that's the question mark a
lot of people had in comments and stuff
i was reading at all but like
your ability to make 50 tackles plus
and still be able to perform but um your
fit as your contact fitness is hurting
so did you you obviously didn't question
your ability to be able to make that
amount of tackles
no no i don't like uh in league they do
make a bunch more tackles in us
um and reunion um but a lot of it
there's
a system in that as well but that yeah
which
like tackling's fine but i i enjoy
tackling there's going to be
a transition period into into making
that mean it just is what it is if you
do something more than you used to
you're going to have to transition to
get used to it um but i was like
that's the wristing side of it that i
reckon would have been a little bit
harder in the
in the defense like making attack with
making tackle but
like they catch a lot of it as well and
tap it quite high so catching wrestling
someone taking him to the ground and
getting him back up
that would have been the heart of it in
the conditioning side of it
but my biggest concern with going in
terms of the time restraint was the
connection with
the team um being able to build
relationships with the team if you're
playing hookah
and you're part of the spine being able
to drive a team around
without knowing anyone really and coming
into the middle of the season
like i don't know i don't know the vibe
of the team i don't know the lads i
don't know
um the dynamic on how we we want to play
like i know coaches have their dynamic
and how they see the game going but
especially in rugby nine cents full
works like we know how we want to play
the game even though the game plan is
the game
the game plan is given to the team like
we sort of understand each other and
what we think we should do in certain
situations and you only build that
through
time and settle with someone so like i
wouldn't be able to have that it would
literally be what's on the board i'm
going to go out there and do that and
there would have been less instinct with
for the relationship then
yeah that's true so had you messaged any
of the boys had you been in contact with
any of the lads you
messaging teddy very often nah i didn't
i didn't because
because i didn't know um what i was
gonna do i didn't want
to to create a relationship
um and then to have to let someone bit
someone down um
yeah like uh coming here
i remember i messaged you and asked for
your brother's number um i was pretty
pretty sure i was coming at that point
um so i was comfortable
to build that relationship and to have
those sorts of conversations
um but when when i knew how split the
decision was i didn't wanna
build a relationship and then have to
let someone down
but you've got a lot of relationships
already with a lot of league stars
brandon smith and stuff he's been
talking about
messaging you you've been asking him for
some advice etc so
yeah how's that relationship work yeah
so we
in lockdown last year um we all got into
nba cards and collected lda cards and so
we started this group
uh you know isaac john um
so he started a group chat and a bunch
of the boys all in there and then when
the whole crossfit overcame came up i
was like man i got some pretty good
players in this chat and i reached out
and messaged um a bunch of them just
which brandon about um
what like he thinks a good hooker is
what conditioning i would need to do if
i was coming
um which is a couple other boys that
play in the hearts about what they
expect from a good hooker
um yeah what what they need from the
hooker in terms of service
in terms of um i don't know um
manipulating defensive with defenses
sorry
with a running game kicking game and
just trying to see
what they thought um the best soccer
look like for them
yeah but did they did what sort of
advice did they give you
what sort of feedback did you get no i
got really good advice from it
like yeah a lot of it wasn't around the
conditioning um
the techniques of it they had the same
thoughts on bro
if you train it you're going to get used
to it simple as that if you
yeah tackling is tackling um you either
want attack or you don't and i i enjoy
technique so i was never worried about
that
um but you just got to condition
yourself for it which is which is fine
um but the understanding
uh bug speed uh when to be able to have
a go
um from a rock and when to when to just
when to serve and
the ability to be crafty around that too
if i think you see a lot of
hookers now at the moment they're like
um breaking out of a wrap right
then pulling back and you're coming back
to the left and that's creating like a
like a mismatch or creating a team to
shift one way
and then you're getting your halves on
like bigger boys going sideways which is
like it's really smart and i never
really watched lee um that way
until i got that feedback wrong from
some of those boys
that's crazy man and you would have been
dead deadly out of dummy half close to
the line
you would have been kicking at least a
couple of 40 20s again
i would have but i would have loved uh
like cooking on that next enjoy like i
i enjoy that kick in rugby so being able
to do that
with 10 meter space i know there's
markers there but for quick right 10
meters of space
you know again so could be it would have
been would be cool yeah honestly how
many 40 20s do you reckon you would have
kicked
and you got 10 games left in the season
right i guarantee i would have attempted
one first game
i definitely would have i would have
tried to give a bad turkey
oh man i'm a little bit gutted that
you're not i'm never going to actually
get to see this i
can yeah it would have been interesting
because it doesn't really happen enough
i don't feel like
union guys jump over the league we don't
really get to see it they've usually
come from league
first like your sunnies and brad thorne
yeah um not many
straight out union guys head over to
league and give it a try but it would
have been awesome to see
yeah i would i would have loved today
like the i still get excited talking
about it now
and yeah like i'm content with the
decision and what um greer and i've
decided to do
but there will always be that part um
you think man that would have been that
would have been a really cool experience
um and like
it's awesome to watch like we obviously
all play supercoach in there and
seeing the boys out there and being
invested in it that way and then
for the last sort of month two months
having a little bit more investment in
it and being like man i could i can do
this and i feel like i haven't done it
really well it's been
that's been cool my super coach team was
desperate for you too
you would have been a super coach
gardener
we can't tell you away
yeah well you would have started at
basement price
would have been interesting to see what
your value was at the end of the season
oh
first million dollar player
is it true you messaged um
adam reynolds was it true you message
and adam reynolds on the april fool's
joke or is that
um was that a stitcher there's someone
pulling my leg there
[Laughter]
um because he's a hanger now he's in
there
i had already reached out to him for
like advice on what he wants from
hookers
yeah and i saw that right and i was like
this could be nice bro
i think it was with your brother and uh
because they saw it too this
[Laughter]
yeah it took me a while to admit it to
your brother and mine
oh crack up so was an option ever to
just stay in japan
or that was never really an option
um yeah it was an option there was an
option to
try and like come back to new zealand
for the six month period and come back
to japan as well so that was
talked about and that was on the table
um or stay in japan
and just come home and race but the big
thing that i had was that like
i like playing a game i like competing
so having
not not playing for i think the season
starts in january so not playing from
now until january just didn't make any
sense to me it
felt like i'd be wasting um some of the
best years of my career
by doing nothing so i wanna i wanted to
be playing
so even though it was tabled i would i
never considered
just doing that sabbatical's never an
option for you
you hate rest we can risk later like
and i know everyone's different like
four's my a little bit different because
they
dispatch each other all the time and
whatever but
i don't want to ever retire and be like
man i
could have had i don't know six months
more game
plan when when it's all said and done i
reckon i would love to
have six months more playing so i don't
want to ever while i'm
at this point in my career which i think
i'm playing some of the best footy i've
played and i want to continue to grow
that
i don't want to rest for that i want to
enjoy that
yeah fair enough so was was money ever a
big factor in it i feel like you're
probably turning down a
huge money in japan to play in new
zealand is that sort of
is that sort of true um yeah there's a
pretty big
offer um here in japan that we're uh
we've said no to um and we're very
um grateful for for the offer and for
um i guess how i was valued
on because effectively when a team makes
you an offer
that's what they're saying they value
that and i know people
don't say it's for the money and stuff
like that and like a lot of the reason
we play this game is because we because
we love the game but we only
get a short time frame in this so when a
company offers you something that's them
showing you
how they value you so to have that sort
of um
compliment i guess i could call it from
from clubs here was
uh was very humbling and um yet we are
taking less money to come home but
when we waited up like it just didn't
matter that time apart
from from my baby like she's nine months
old now and i've been
absent in her life over half of that but
i've only been with her
um three of those nine months or three
in a bit of those nine months so
it it wasn't worth risking that again
like i
don't i can't risk that again yeah
no that's fair enough so um something
you've talked about before is in terms
of money is
players should be more open with how
much money they're getting is that do
you still sort of feel like that
yeah like with each other no i don't
think i should sign a contract and go on
post
yeah i'm a big believer there right we
should know what
our peer is doing yeah the only person
who doesn't
the only person who wins if we don't
know is the club or is the
um company that is paying you because
they can if you got two players i don't
know
who assigned for the same position
sharing the same amount of minutes
producing the same amount
but one of them's earning say one dollar
and the other one's earning 65 cents for
that dollar
yeah and you'd never know unless you two
communicate because the the company's
not gonna say oh i'm paying him a dollar
and do 65 cents
they're not gonna tell you that because
then then you'll be like well i'm
producing the same thing
and what i reckon it does give um for
players the power it gives the players
is
they can see that compromise they can
see uh where they sit so
we all know in our hearts
like where we think we are and compared
to the people in our positions compared
to the people who are playing with
but you know where we're about you sit
so if you're
getting so much more like so much less
money than someone that you know you're
better than or someone that you know
you're performing at a higher level then
or playing more minutes then
like you have that ability to negotiate
that to be like man i'm i'm producing
all of this
the bro over here is not and he's
getting paid that
but i feel like i should be getting paid
more but yeah and it's not a knock on
each other and that's where i think
people get um
confused with it it's not me looking at
the the guy next to me saying [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's just me saying like i can see what
i'm producing i can see what you're
producing
i still want you to get paid but i want
everyone to get paid and get paid well
but me knowing what you're getting
allows me to negotiate
so i can get paid more too all right
you're talking a lot of sense there
there's some real talk right there
because um
it doesn't happen no one everyone keeps
their contract secret and it's always
been that way and
i feel like people are the guys who are
getting paid a lot are embarrassed about
how much they're getting paid and the
guys who um who aren't getting paid they
i guess they're embarrassed as well
because they're not getting paid
i remember we've got this like real bad
relationship with money i remember
growing up
my mum and dad would always say don't
eat don't ask people what they don't
like you just never even do that you
don't talk about money
and that creates like a really bad
relationship with money
and i i can see like people would
probably
like their embarrassment they don't oh
la and there's a lot of bands in rugby
circles so
if you if people start to know what each
other's on
people might get afraid of their banter
but like banter's that's part of it and
i'm very open with anyone if they ask me
what i'm earning regardless what
position they play if they want to know
so that they can
um i don't know negotiate their contract
then like i would i want that person to
have that that knowledge you know it's
uh
it's so much more empowering as a person
when you know what situation you're
going into because if you walk into a
negotiation
and the guy says oh this is the most we
can pay you
and you've got nothing to measure that
against yeah like
of course like you signed their contract
yeah no no doubt
but in league it's a little bit
different it feels like everyone knows
the media knows straight away what god's
going to make i
saw a few figures come out for you
of what your offers were at um the
roosters so
um yeah which i i think that it's sort
of a little bit
the other way though because i see a lot
of players getting
social media abuse that sort of stuff
for being a high pay player
and obviously not performing as a
million dollar player or whatever
or whatever they're earning so a few
guys um have come under the pump that
way but
um so how do you feel about it that side
uh-huh starters they're pretty accurate
[Music]
i think my wife sent me on know as my
cousin actually
sent me stuff that they threw out about
some japanese contracts and that but
there must have been nrl
reporters doing it because they weren't
accurate with that but then
like spot-on on the bottom
yeah i noticed that those league one oh
those those japan ones were way
understood that league one
that that league one so it wasn't a huge
amount of money to go to the roosters
that wasn't ever really a part of it
now the money wasn't a part of the day
like it it was
i really wanted the to test myself and
the experience and
i thought i could do it well and i
begged myself to take that contract
and play well and then earn my worth in
the in the nrl
um so that that was always my mindset on
it
um in terms of how
like the media go out and i think
one of the bros that you were talking
about
who gets who's been cooking a bit of
stick
for being paid that much like what i
don't get what i didn't struggle with
is that they don't they say that we're
overpaid players are overpaid and stuff
like that
but where did where do they want that
money to go do they want
like people who are sitting above us and
not playing to be getting paid more i
don't i don't quite understand it you
know like
yeah the i don't i don't like the
ability for people to abuse regardless i
don't care if it's about money or what
it's about
but it's there um i think the
the positive that we get as players
understanding what
our environment's on and what people are
getting outweighs the negative
that i know your average person's gonna
write something bad about me
like someone will watch this clip that
we're gonna put up
this podcast and they're going to say
something bad about me about footy like
tears
yeah yeah this is what it is you're
going to disagree with my view on the
money side of it so
my kids i would rather the environment
and the people around me and
future kids coming through have more
understanding more power
to make decisions more than i care about
what
someone's going to say about it oh
you're a lad
absolutely
was it was it ever an option to be paid
in cryptocurrency i know you're quite
big on it
um i i'd love to uh like i reckon
yeah new zealand athlete
especially a portion of it um
i think it i think it's smart i've been
thinking about it a little bit actually
and
trooper lawrence i think he signed his
um
sign on button he just got drafted first
in the nfl
and i was trying to work out why he
would why he did that
like why wouldn't you just take the
money and then buy your cryptocurrency
like why would you
and my understanding is he so just say
he is a million dollars i think there's
twenty four million dollar sign on so if
you got paid that you get if you taxed
on that and then he could buy his
cryptocurrency
but if you get 24 million dollars worth
of bitcoin
you get 24 million worth of bitcoin you
don't get
the 39 tax or the 50 tax
on top of that you know so that's
probably why so it makes so much sense
to me
to do that so was it is it
i i don't know i don't know if you can
do that
and definitely with conversation i'd
love to have a conversation about it
well in two and a half years
so what are you excited about of getting
back to new zealand and playing
trying to make the all blacks again
what's motivating you
um bro yeah i'm really excited
to to get home to be our family to um
play for the hurricanes
um and and try my goal let's play for
north so i'm really excited about that
um i think another thing that's really
driving me at the moment is i've
probably got i've got a new respect for
um for rugby um and it actually came up
yesterday this conversation with in in
the league who were actually having a
conversation about league
and saying like it's been the hardest
four months of my life
and how much i appreciate being an
athlete and how much respect i have for
training and stuff
um to help me through this
like this time and then that
conversation finished and i was like man
i actually think it's the respect i have
for rugby has changed
i've always loved the game i always give
everything to the game um but i reckon i
did that because i wanted to be better
all the time i
i wanted to keep getting better and play
at a higher level and be a better rugby
player
not because of how much the game has
given me
and and reflect reflecting over this
last
um four months like it's it's been
the constant for me it's been um
something that's really helped me
through some tough times
so i feel like i owe i owe it to rugby
to
to come back into um
to give to give rugby to i
i don't want to say i i disrespect the
brain because i've always trained hard
but it's
yeah the mindset when i'm training now
the
applications the detail when i'm in a
meeting
is it's for a different reason it's it's
not as much for me anymore it's because
i want
um to give back to the game for how it's
helped me especially through
this last four months man that's
powerful stuff
um yeah so that's and that's that only
sort of clip after
it it's weird but it's after that lead
conversation when i thought
that's what my feelings were about
training and then i reflected on i was
like man it's actually my feelings about
rugby and that was another um
sort of big big um eye-opening moment
was like
if i don't go back to rugby like i'll
never be able to repay it for how it
helped me now
yeah cool good wow
wow
oh i love it
so all blacks is that is that the goal
get that number nine jersey build
towards this
world cup yeah 100 like it's
it's always been uh my goal and now
being back in new zealand rugby
uh it continues to be my goal i i love
competing
at the highest level and with some of
the best players in the world we've got
some really good nines in new zealand
and i'm really looking forward to that
competition and to
continue to try and be better and yeah
starting for the all blacks is
my massive goal it's it's my dream and
it's what i want to do
um but i'm also really excited about the
process of that too that's that's the
end result
um but i'm really excited about that
process of
of training hard playing well turning up
every day and trying to be better that's
that's something that's really driving
me too
who's impressed you from stepping out of
the new zealand rugby scene to watching
from afar
you've obviously been watching a lot of
super rugby altera
who's impressed you i think outside of
webby and nagi who i i think are
awesome players and obviously incumbent
all black nines
um i really liked philo when he was when
he was playing
early i thought he was um really really
good he obviously had a really good
um mitre 10 cup and then
like got him for him and his injury like
i messaged him pretty much straight away
when he got injured because you never
you never want to see it especially when
someone's going good man like he's yeah
he's playing playing really well um so i
was excited watching him play
um and then i i'm really impressed with
triple t like i know he hasn't had it
um his way a lot of time
over the last couple years but with his
opportunity he got this year
he's playing at a really high level he
made a massive impact for
for that chief's team um when he came on
the field
um and then lastly i thought sam knock
was really good
he didn't he didn't play heaps of games
i think he might have only played four
or five
um but he was he was he was good man
like it is
they've got uh finlay and jonathan up
there as well
um who are both uh really good players
but i thought when sam knock was playing
um
he looked really really sharp sure so
who do you think all blacks will go with
for their third half back until you get
called in for injury recover
oh man i don't know
so
i'd like to see them go
well that's tough or something i think i
think the conversation is going to be
about
um probably it will be triple t i think
sam knock will be in the conversation
and i think one of the crusaders will be
in the conversation too because although
i didn't mention them
um i probably don't and people don't
talk about
mitchell brynn that much but because
they're always so
consistently good people take that for
granted almost
um so they they they expect principle
out there and play well they expect
michigan out there and play well and
when they do that
nothing's really said about it but if
you if you're not expected to do it
and you go and do it like there's a lot
more noise about it so i think that
it'll be the conversation out of those
four
sorry and finally christie's definitely
in there too i'd say
yeah yeah he's he's a good player talk
about talk to me about the hurricanes
you're obviously watching the hurricanes
for the first
time for a long long time since 08 or
something
so what was it like being out of the
team watching from afar
watching the hurricanes go to work um
i didn't like it i didn't like dropping
out of to impact it and not being able
to be a part of the environment
um it was hard man it was hard like
i love the team i love the boys and i
want to see us do well
but not being able to impact the
environment
um not being able to go out on the field
it was tough
and stuff it was hard to just sit back
and enjoy the games because i wanted to
be there
so much yeah what do you what were they
missing where did they
where'd they struggle you think um
well we lost a few close games which
really hurts
like it's it's such a short competition
um that if you if you lose a couple
early games and a couple close ones
like it can have a real impact um
on the on the team and on the
environment um so that
like closing our games hurt us
as a team and that um sort of
had a had a flow and effectiveness to
the next games it's it's hard to
put a finger on it when i'm not in the
environment i'm not there day to day
um because i thought we did place on
some really good 44 for big portions of
it
um and then just yeah we're unlucky not
to
close a couple of those games yeah a lot
of games are lost by small margins and
yeah
yeah like you said those that those key
moments towards the end back end of
games is
definitely something that they missed
which were you which you were always a
guru at
closing out games
[Laughter]
that's um i don't know
about that it's crazy
it's um it's not easy right like
i've been in games where i've lost those
games like in the weekend we lost the
game
we probably should have closed out um
they took you off though
like there's a couple games in our
season here
that if we hadn't lost him at the depth
when we won them
like our season looks real different and
that's it's like a couple minutes
one decision one play that can be the
difference between you
looking at having like a really
successful season or
looking like your team struggle so it's
hard to point one thing sometimes
it is crazy yeah and last thing before
you before you sign with the
keynes was it always the case because i
know you messaged me and you said you're
going to the blues
which which i didn't believe for a
second
but was it was it ever an option to go
to another um super rugby side
no no no not for me it's um
like my whole family's in wellington um
yeah
that's been my home for so long my
wife's family's there
at home like i i couldn't imagine
um playing for another team or coming
home to new zealand and not being in
wellington so they'll help
it wasn't an option at all yeah
you weren't you weren't
[Laughter]
anyway as always gone to our instagram
for some questions and
i always say that we've got heaps for
them heaps of questions but i don't
usually i'm usually lying but today
when you come on man so many so many
questions
you you must have reposted it because
it's absolutely blown up
but to be fair a lot of them are just
wishing that you've got roosters friends
hoping that you're coming to the
roosters we've got hurricanes fans
hoping you're coming back we've got
japanese fans saying please stay in
japan
so many of them are those sort of
comments so it just shows you how much
people are wanting you to be part of the
assignment
thanks bro um first question this is
from your bro actually
king of the hill around 15 years ago
talked me through
what happened today
um or playing king of the hill
um down at the beach and
me and him bro like compete at
everything everybody i'm really
competitive and it's
more so with him but whereas
yeah that's not good and he's he's
exactly the same
with me yeah what yeah what's going on
the hill
king of the hill so like everyone starts
at the bottom of the hill
and you've got to try and get to the top
it's like bull rush but
and i was in the middle like i was the
tattler on that one
yeah and there was heaps of us there and
we've been competing all day and like
annoying each other
and i was like well i'm gonna get him
straight away he's gonna be the first
one i give
and he was going up the hill and i let
him go past me and act like
he like i wasn't going to get him and
then i ran out and i like tackled him
from behind
and last cracking up and laughing at him
and like getting smarter
and he just turns around brandon
he's like straight in the face bro
no good like bleeding and everything
there's nothing
and then like we're always like upset
with him you know that's hillary and he
like walked to the passport
and he was going to catch the budget we
were walking off
and he called out to us bro i've got no
money
to get to the bus
[Laughter]
yeah and we were both like overweight
growing up or both like chubbier i
hadn't seen it it would have been maybe
six months
since i'd seen him and then he turned up
and i was like bro
i've got abs now that's right
[Laughter]
and then that's where it all sort of
like went back and forth throughout the
day
and then that was the tipping point
[Laughter]
wow that is good stuff okay
next question what led you to making
deals with under armour and powerade
over others
um so under our deal was
there was a a conversation pretty much
so i
sat down with um a couple of the team
there under armour
and a big part of why i signed with
under armour
they led the conversation with um
a community based idea so it had nothing
to do with money it's
like i had nothing to do with money
there um their pitch
had nothing to do with me really to be
here
it had to do with how they wanted to
help communities and how
they wanted to help the athletes
communities as well so
they want they by being with under ammo
gave me a really good opportunity to
help put it all and that was
like when they labeled that that didn't
really matter what else they said after
it i was pretty keen
that's cool empire power is a really um
awesome company to work with i've worked
with them um
like not directly but like through the
all blacks and stuff like that
and i've always enjoyed the team um the
team there so
when they reached out um the people that
were involved i had been with before i
had talked with before and i've i've
always had um
really positive connections with them so
being able to work with them and being
able to work with those people
that's why i wanted to be a part of that
team
um the ad is still one of my favorite
ads on telly i like that
i get so much for that
[Laughter]
like everyone gives me [ __ ] for a man
like they
yeah but i reckon because because i end
up coming here so we would have done
another
shoot in december of last year to for
the children
i was here we just ran with it again you
know
hopefully yeah
[Laughter]
okay next question well
what's what's your favorite japanese
word
my favorite japanese word um
[Music]
but i i pro my favorite sentence
probably is like
kinowan oh
whenever i ask someone a question like
that i had no idea what their answer was
can you understand what they're saying
when they answer those questions
um yeah well a lot of it's
so when you ask that so okay he sits
across from
tom and tom and i are next to marty um
so i'll often talk with him first
because he speaks
pretty good english too and then so i'll
ask him then he'll
reply to me and then
i'll ask him what he said and then and a
lot of people say something similar you
know something similar oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah so i so now like my dialogue
is a little bit especially around like
real basic stuff like how are you how's
your family
what'd you do yesterday what are you
doing for lunch yourself
oh you're a wizard and you're obviously
still learning um too
yeah yeah i'm still learning i think i
i made a conscious effort to learn the
hong kong while i was here and
not focus as much on maori um
i'm about being here and i wanted to
keep
learning maori and he said it's like
it's really maori
to dive into another culture while
you're on their land as well
so um as much as i continue
want to continue to learn maori and i
have continued to learn maori i really
wanted to dive into the culture here and
uh embrace it and respect it and give it
um
the the respect it deserves that i think
a lot of foreigners
come over here and stick in like a
foreign group and don't
um don't dive in as much and yeah i
really
yeah i wanted to to be a part of it
nice this sort of leads on to this
question
how have you found being vegan in japan
it's been it's been tough it's um i've
got like a select
group of things that i can eat
which is a lot of meat there's a lot of
meat here
a lot of meat um but i'll cover that
same guy i was talking to he
um orders me stuff like vegan stuff that
i get delivered here
um oh true you can't really eat out then
can you
ah there's like three or four places
there pretty good two two
there's two places um we can eat it uh
it's pretty good
and then that training because we get
lunch and dinner and they have like a
they make me a vegan feed as well
oh yeah oh yeah which is all good okay
this one this one's from
obviously a wode lad listener he wants
to hear the backstory of what happened
in the
3 a.m yo-yo bit with snakey how did it
happen
he didn't turn up bro i'm telling you
snakey didn't turn out he was past
3am nights at that stage of his career
so we made the bet and he didn't turn up
to a boy
he um he's still gutted too because
we've never run a yoyo against each
other
but i saw him run a yo-yo at the fire up
top of
the hurricane when he was coming back
after his sabbatical but he was doing a
bite himself
oh sure yeah and he ran like
would it be i think it was like an
eighteen five or an eighteen six
really oh yeah but like but he was just
like cruising back into
he still he still had eight weeks away
until he was playing but he just came
back and just
got it and bro
[Laughter]
yo-yos and running after we build a
relationship i was like i remember
when you hit
[Laughter]
[Music]
dude and i was coming back again when i
saw that nah
it's not good enough
oh that's so good
okay were you ever considering the
warriors
um yep yeah i was but the
i gave my word my word sorry to trent
um quite early on um that if i did come
to league
um i'd go to the roosters so um
that they end up being like if
if any other club had offered me like a
bunch more
um money i would have gone to to the
roosters because i told him like
i was really thankful that he had
reached out that he um
saw it as an option uh before you know i
now shootingly
um head so i told him i would do that
and he
um he had told me about some of the
restrictions on salary cap and stuff
like that and they didn't have a bunch
of money
um they're there and but it didn't
matter
like i i'd given him my word so that's
where i would have gone
maybe potentially after that like
after going to the roosters potentially
going to another club could have been an
option but
for this year was it was them that first
one
nice okay on that which roosters
teammate
are you or slash were you looking most
forward to playing with
oh but there's a couple
like obviously titty's pretty amazing
like he's a
he's crazy good player boy um so to be
able to be around someone at that level
um would have been would have been
really cool
um sammy walker bro he's
he's the future he's going to be
something really good so it's so
somewhat like on the
opposite scale almost someone just
starting but
still in terms of talent like but just
like he's amazing what he's doing out on
the field so to be able to be around
someone
um through that growth part of their
career um that would have been that
would have been really cool
and i think you two would have formed
their you guys would have formed a cool
partnership to grow over the years
too that would have been cool though it
would have been cool and
there's another young kid i don't want
to pronounce his name wrong but i think
it's swally
the center yep joseph yeah yeah
i think he would have been really good
too and then um
joey manu like he seems like a lad and
he goes hard as well
so that would be really cool stack
there's teammate morris brothers or they
won brett's gone
yeah a few kiwis over there too yeah
yeah yeah
bro how good okay last one
what changes would you make to your
training regime if you were to make the
switch
um changes what i've made
i reckon like the the big fitness
difference would be the down and
upperness so i'll probably be
adding any more down up though we don't
do heaps of down and up fitness
um there's a nine in rugby
yeah but in the league obviously making
tackles
getting up getting back 10 coming
forward and doing it again
and wrestling i think would they would
have been the two um big adjustments
that i would have made
but it's my chance but you're always a
good wrestler to
i remember a few pre-seasons at the
canes i think you might have checked me
out once or twice
i got your brother this year too yeah
no no that you would have been a league
guru but i might honestly
really excited about the news going back
to mccain's
new zealand rugby i know decisions in my
career every
time i've had a decision has been really
tough i've always found it really
stressful and i've been working with
pennies and one or two options but
you've had
20 000 different options huges and huge
amounts of cash to
weigh up so i'm just i'm just happy that
you've got the decision that you
and your family are happy with and yeah
like i said we're looking forward to you
back in that seeing you back in that
keynes jersey and the all blacks jersey
cheers bro thanks so much for having me
and giving me um i guess the platform to
be able to
to say like what what happened um the
decision why are the decisions my
thought process behind it like
with media and that nowaday um sometimes
their angle gets
manipulated at the start so to be able
to do it here um
first is uh it's been a really cool
opportunity so thank you for for
allowing me that bro on your platform
mate hey thanks for choosing the willard
podcast you're an absolute lad you're
the biggest lad
cheers cheers brother thanks so much